that's the 2015 hit leaned on by Major
Lazer and it's renowned DJ Diplo the
song racked up more than 1 billion
streams on how mattify 1 billion be
Rolling Stone calls less attention
better known as Diplo one of the most
in-demand producers in music he's won
two Grammys for song - Justin Bieber and
fellow DJ Skrillex and his energetic
performances make him one of the Forbes
highest-paid DJs in the world up he is
no joke he knows what he's doing a new
documentary called give me future
explores Diplo's historic performance in
Cuba last year look at this crowd Major
Lazer was a fruit made major lazer
rather was the first major American
group to play there in more than five
decades so the movie looks at the
groundbreaking performance in Havana
there's not gonna be another first
moment when someone comes to Cuba do
shows not gonna ever be this another
inaugural concert like this so even if
it sucks let's do that every artist begs
for like a moment in time where people
are paying attention to you and you know
when you're gets it gets to you we have
to seize the moment because it's not
gonna happen again
Wesley fence also known as Diplo joins
us now at the table good morning to you
Diplo aka Wesley pence your morning
let's just say it did not suck it did
not suck it and this is what I want you
to set the scene for us because when you
guys got there you weren't even sure how
many people would show up you thought
maybe 10 maybe 20 but at the end of the
day how many people showed up and what
did you think when you look across that
sea of humanity well it was almost
450,000 people at the concert and for us
yeah like I said we were happy just to
have a couple of fans there we weren't
sure if anybody in Cuba had heard of us
at her music we had no idea how in touch
they were with music in different ways
so we were just anticipating something
you know something small something you
know cool and then once the day started
rolling on and people started walking up
in a farm 2 a.m. just kind of walking
such an antiquated internet system yeah
so what is surprising that they knew
about you but they did if if you watch
the film we went down there and we
decided to make a film about our
experiences you know one thing I told
the director Austin Peters that's like
don't make this film about us about our
vacation or whatever going to Cuba let's
find the story's there you know in the
film ended up being about a USB key yeah
and it's called the big cat a what it is
it's like an analog Internet and what
happens is people trade music and they
trade information through the island
through one USB key I've heard down the
streets and that's how people found out
about literally taking it nor from one
person to the next and then he sends it
then he sends it and he sends it yeah it
was it was amazing to see that in 2007
the way that music can be in some ways
political because Cuba of course is a
communist nation with limits on free
speech and expression how did you find
that I mean performing there well we had
it work hand in hand with the government
to arrive there wasn't easy I think our
music was a bit easier for them to
accept we don't really have any
political views we don't do any
profanity nothing very negative in our
music so for us they they loved the kind
of records like lean on or lighted up
burgers that are about self-discovery by
helping yourself and I think lyrically
and our content was easy for the
government to to help us with so we're
working hand in hand with them as well
as the US government the embassy down
there we kind of found the right way to
navigate we were like the woman group
that was able to go there I think my
other groups had tried but we were kind
of like the one that they chose that was
the right one
I even like the title of the documentary
I didn't know what it meant before I
started watching it but give me future
because so many people say you know this
is an old country nobody comes here but
the fact that these guys came here give
me a future and make me feel alive I
want to know what that meant to you and
what was your takeaway for your and when
you left there are our experiences in
Cuba like you know said the Rolling
Stones are there as well and it's it's
always like a nostalgic thing because
Cuba has this a nostalgic feeling you go
there you feel like the old cars that's
kind of old history and you don't
realize there's you know over 10 million
people then there's kids there and there
wouldn't be part of the world they want
to feel like they're part of what we're
doing and it did feel like this is their
moment this is the moment we're all
together they're a part of global music
they're a part of something that they
all know they all love and they know for
me I just feel like we're so close to
cue with our neighbors I just nice to
have some sympathy for the people there
the kids because they're trying to live
just like us every day and everybody
lived the same life and something like
this happens to them
a giant concert the one experience you
know that we had been part of it it's
just amazing to kind of see the growth
and explosion I thought we went there
there's be the beginning of many many
concerts like there's gonna be a huge
amount of Americans go in their concerts
but it really was the only thing now the
doors are kind of closing because we
passed different laws I think really
recently about traveling in and so we
don't know what's gonna happen again you
had an amazing career not bad for a guy
whose soul who made mixtapes in his
bedroom and you know you are the one of
the number one DJs in the world mister
Diplo well you know it started it's my
path was very different than a lot of
other musicians but um I think just
learning learning my way through it all
kind of I think it's the exploring
different ways to do it thank you
well love that memory of making mixtapes
yes or good times thank you